pull your oreas on the mound for the
Dodgers 20-3 with the 296 era during the
regular season 1-0 the 360 era here in
this postseason brings up Ozzy Alby
Ozzie Albee's with Freddie Freeman at
first base
and a little jab shot pop up gonna be a
tough play Bellinger's got a long way to
go over the shoulder oh makes a catch
nice play by Cody Bellinger nice to have
Center Fielder's Wheels playing first
base and it's out number two a beautiful
play Jesse Chavez gets the start as the
opener for the Atlanta Braves don't
expect him around very long the 38 year
old right-hander from Fontana and the
Braves looking to solve Corey Seger he
hit his seventh postseason home run
against the Braves in yesterday's ball
game
all seven coming over the last two
nlcs's 1-0 pitch comebacker over the
mound Ozzie backhand stop long throw
over in time what a spectacular play by
Ozzie Albee's momentum carrying him out
to left field Mack can stop spawning
through Rosario's been leading off but
with the left-hander Urias out there
he's batting in the in the fifth hole
score of this game here the top of the
second Eddie smacks one to deep left
this will send back Taylor with urgency
he's back in the wall that's out of the
ballpark Eddie Rosario drops the hammer
on that pitch and it's one nothing
Braves took him the other way that ball
was drilled Here Comes Adam Duvall
number 3-2 on the way that is destroyed
high in the air deep to the wall and
you've got yourself Double Trouble on
back-to-back home runs in the top of the
second
Adam Duvall with a high arcing bomb over
the center field wall
[Applause]
swing two out in Dansby Swanson coming
up
the 1-1
pop-up and a short left center field
coming on in Chris Taylor waving his
arms making the call in the catch and
the inning is over Lux was in the
starting lineup yesterday walked twice
three and two on locks on the pitch on
the way from Smiley lift into the air to
deep center field this will send back
Adam Duvall he's at the wall he leaves
and Adam I believe he may the catch he
did
and here we go to the third with Freddie
Freeman leading off
two and one to Freeman
Linda right field got some carry to it
that's his back at the wall and this one
is gone the Atlanta Braves with the long
ball Freddie Freeman this time three to
nothing Braves on the third solo home
run of the night
now to Eddie Rosario and Eddie got
everything going for the Braves in
Indigo when he let off the second inning
with a home run
and that Ball's down the line on the Run
bench cannot get there two hops off the
fence Rosario around second on his way
to third the throw comes in and it is a
triple for Rosario flying around the
bases Runners of the corners two down
for Jack Peterson Peterson with 12
homers his last five years in the
postseason had a key two run Homer in
game two
up in a big spot
one and two in the air center field off
the end of the bat coming in fast Lux
cannot get there a base hit Rosario will
score
four to nothing Atlanta
has Peterson drives in a run
right off the into the bat it died in
center field and a two-out hit for jock
Peterson and the Braves are up 4-0
Travis darno coming up
and darno with a Fly ball to right field
drifting on back that's a couple of
steps in front of the warning track will
make the catch Swanson is over two three
and two with one out top of the fourth
praise four to nothing Swanson Strikes
Out Swinging and there's two outs first
strikeout of the game for urius second
out of the fourth two out Freddie
Freeman has walked and homered today the
O2 Freeman Strikes Out Swinging and
that'll end the inning verse one two
three inning for urius he has struck out
two and after three and a half in the
fourth game in the National League
Championship Series it's the phrase four
the Dodgers Eddie Rosario coming to the
plate first pitch on the way serve down
to right field that is down for a base
hit around second heading for third
Ozzie Albee's he'll Cruise in and
Eddie's got the single out of the way
this guy's unbelievable four nothing
Braves Runners of the corners one down
and here's Duvall 2-1 pitch on the way
it's one of the year to center field
behind it Gavin Lux he has got it Ozzy
will test his arm tags from third comes
home and now in between first and third
they would have had Rosario hung up the
ball is cut off by Bellinger but no one
was there to cover first base and he
just cruises right on back to the bag a
run scores on the sac fly and it's five
nothing Atlanta that's jock Peterson
step
in Step 1-2 Peterson Strikes Out
Swinging on a breaking ball down and
away that will end the inning
but the Braves tack on another run on
two hits they leave one and after four
and a half it's Atlanta five and the
Dodgers nothing AJ Pollock is now going
to pinch hit for urius Justin Turner
leading off third Bellinger from second
the 1-1 from Chris Martin to AJ Pollock
ground ball base hit in the right center
field in the score is Turner and here
comes kellinger Holland with a two RBI
pinch hit the Dodgers are back in
business Atlanta five and the Dodgers
too Eddie Rosario due to hit with two
outs here in the seventh two balls two
strikes for all delivers Rosario Strikes
Out Swinging in that NCAA
Justin Turner singled and scored in the
fifth inning nobody out thrower at first
Walker Bueller pinch rolling for pool
holes
on the ground got a chance to turn two
here it'll be Elvis by himself and a
double play and Turner is hurt
Turner has been playing with a bad
hamstring
and I think it got him right there he
pulled up about three quarters of the
way up the wide big opportunity for
Freddie Johnson deals Freeman down the
right field line hooks one that is going
to be a fair ball and it bounces out and
this will produce a run the automatic
double by Freddie Freeman and the Braves
was it Insurance rung here in the ninth
it is six to two Atlanta so now Eddie
Rosario will climb into the left-hand
batters box 1-1 pitch Rosario hits one
well to deep right field back at the
wall that one is gone
Rosario knocked The Living Daylights out
of it
over the right field wall and it's a 9-2
Braves lead in the ninth
what's around the bases
thousands are trotting for the exits
Will Smith climbs up to the plate for
the Dodgers to face Will Smith Center
Field that balls hit well Heredia going
back on it and he makes the play to end
the game the Atlanta Braves are one went
away from their first World Series
appearance since
1999. they win game four nine to two
Michelob Ultra organic Seltzer as real
as it tastes